Recipes are great, because usually the end
product is something pretty tasty, like a cake.
>> I love cake.
>> Me, too. But the bad thing about recipes
is, you kind of have to stick to the
recipe, and if you change something, even something small,
you can end up with a change that's really insignificant...
>> Or a really big change.
>> And If we think of our genome as a big book of
recipes, then we can pull from these
individual recipes to make individual proteins, and
we call these individual recipes genes. A gene is
just a sequence of DNA that codes for something.
>> So, let's bring these back to blood
type. You're saying that we have these Individual
genes that create A,B or O proteins and
that dictates what kind of blood type we have.
>> Actually and this A,B,O gene that creates this
proteins if we change it a little bit that
can change the protrein right and then that protein
may give us type A or type B or
could elimate the protein all together and we get no type or type O.